holy
mother forking shirt balls
what wow
okay okay
yo mikey sean come on out
is everything okay right is rain mikey
my boy
so chidi and i are gonna go to the bad
place
what trust me i've got this that's our
decision
let's hit it well what about real life
no it's me and chidi
call the train point of order i don't
accept this offer
the real mistakes were jason and ellen
you said any two of us
it's me and chidi let's do it to it
michael i just found an obscure
precedent in the rules that might just
save everyone fuzz off bamba john
don't need it oh okay
ready when you are boss eleanor what's
going on
it took me a while to figure it out but
just now as we were all
fighting and yelling at each other and
each one of us demanding we should go to
the bad place
i thought to myself man this is torture
and then it hit me they're never gonna
call a train to take us to the bad place
they can't because we're already here
this is the bad place
oh man i can't believe you figured it
out
oh god you ruined everything you know
that
babe there you are i've been let me stop
you can i guess
you've been worried sick about me
i'm headed to the gym sure
why not i'm quite confused let me
explain gorgeous
i don't know what this place is but it
is certainly not the good place
michael is forking with us
michael what do we do here i don't know
apparently the bad place knows that one
of you actually belongs down there with
them and they want that person to get
inside the obelisk or they're going to
take all of you
i can't go i'm too young to die and too
old to eat off the kids and then you
what a stupid age i am i've never
survived down there they should take
eleanor she's a pear-shaped she'd fit
right in oh excuse me you wish you could
have a bite of this pair i'll go i
deserve to go you guys can stay oh
yeah no i have one that's exactly why i
should be doing it
holy forking shirt you guys
don't you get it michael is torturing us
that's why our lives have been so
miserable since the moment we got here
this isn't the good place it's the bad
place
ah farts my love
my sweet dewdrop i have written you
a three hour spoken word jazz
opera cool
eleanor less and more who's it for
for you my dewdrop creamer the crap top
to the bob to the pop to the top
okay no what no no version of heaven
for anyone would ever include three
hours of
this we're in the bad place aren't we
damn it that was a real trip for
biscuits and now we're all wet daddy-o
i never even got to play my stupid
triangle attempt 57.
attempt 99. attempt 108.
i've analyzed some recent data eleanor
always seems to realize that they're in
the bad place just at the moment excuse
me
sorry the door was open so i just came
in did you just say i'm in the bad place
attempt 109 i've closed and locked the
door
yep and we're ready to go hang
on wait a minute you know what holy
smokes this is the bad place
this is the bad place this is the bad
place
this is the bad place the pig's getting
angry this
is the bad place these beef beef
oh this is the bad place
i mean why even bother at this point i'm
obviously
never gonna get it right i'm eleanor i'm
so smart i'm actually in the bad place
sean still thinks i'm on version two i
just keep lying to him it's really bad
but i
i mean i have to keep trying i'm in too
deep and i'm really
fat right now i'm stress eating and i'm
gaining weight in my thighs i mean look
at that
so sorry who are you and where am i
it doesn't matter this one doesn't even
count you simply cannot expect
chidi to decide whether or not they're
bracing
check it is there something messed up
with this place we keep fighting with
each other
none of the tvs get the nfl red zone
channel
my soulmate doesn't even know who blake
bortles is i know this sounds crazy
but i think we're in the bad place
jason figured it out jason this is a
real low point
yeah this one hurts ow
where is everyone who knows maybe they
finally figured out clam chowder is
disgusting because it's basically a
savory latte with bugs in it
is someone smoking a cigar
michael really screwed this up the
regular bad place was
fine if the four-headed flying bears
ain't broke don't fix him what was wrong
with impaling
i loved impaling hey todd got a light
uh yeah obviously i have a light you
know you guys aren't supposed to be
smoking
you're supposed to keep your human suit
on those suits are really itchy for us
who even cares if they see us they're
just gonna get rebooted anyway
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god this is the bad
place i [ __ ] knew it
and clam chowder is disgusting it's just
hot ocean milk with dead animal croutons
what do we do panic freak i usually
panic but i am happy to freak don't you
get it they're torturing you they're
torturing all of us
because this is the bad place
oh man i can't believe you figured it
out
wait he's right this is the bad place
yeah damn it he's right yeah we had a
good run though didn't we yeah we did
so no best place
never change bud
you